okay so this carnivore literally just  had steak all day long i think with some  butter some salt maybe a bit of cheese  in there and maybe some milk not sure  how you wouldn't get bored as [ __ ] that  take an occasional beef meal is fine but  this is not a sustainable diet  definitely not for the environment but  also not great for your health folks  variety's the spice of life i've been  doing the carnivore diet since december  2017.  it's 100 sustainable and most people on  it aren't on it for fun yeah variety is  the spice of life not if it causes you  autoimmunity or severe depression then  variety is not the spice of life and  everyone who's commenting on the  carnivore diet i would like them to try  it for three months before being the  dietitian versus carnivore like what do  dietitians teach people  to follow the  food pyramid which has just made  everybody in america fat don't go to a  dietitian  unless you want to follow the food  pyramid and get fat